thank you for joining us Ukraine's
President Vladimir zielinski has visited
the southern kershawan region to inspect
evacuation operations large parts of the
area underwater after a dam was breached
on Tuesday zelenski praised rescue crews
and discuss getting clean water and
other relief supplies into the disaster
Zone thousands of people have been
forced from their home since the
novakafka dam was damaged zelenski has
called for more International help and
from Aid agencies
links the banks of the dinipro river
held by Russia to the South and Ukraine
to the north
Kiev and Moscow have accused each other
of deliberately attacking the reservoir
the governor of kerson says about 600
square kilometers are underwater he says
32 percent of of it is in
ukrainian-controlled territory and that
the remaining 68 percent is in Russian
occupied territory let's go live to Al
jazeera's Charles Stratford who's in
Kirsten force in the affected area so
the president zielinski has visited this
area what did he see and what's the
latest Charlie on evacuation efforts
Where You Are
well as you rightly say yeah evacuation
efforts are ongoing um president
zielinski here congratulating and
thanking Emergency Services the
situation here though is still dire
we've spoken to volunteers we've
actually been bit out on a boat this
morning as well and we've seen some of
the people still either trapped or
refusing to leave their buildings a lot
of elderly a lot of them firm we've seen
volunteers handing out water to people
trapped in buildings
we've seen a lot of people also some of
the injured have brought out on the ramp
behind me and put into ambulances I mean
you can imagine it's three days now
almost since this it's the third day
since the uh since the dam was destroyed
so for the vulnerable for the week for
the elderly they may not have had access
to water and sufficient food we've also
heard though this morning quite a lot of
shelling a lot more than we heard
yesterday we understand the majority of
it to be outgoing the military here very
nervous that Russian forces across the
river in Russian occupied areas could
mount an attack but there is an
understanding that um that on the
Russian control side as well there are
also ongoing evacuations there are big
fears here also about the availability
of drinking water we've seen tanks water
tanks being brought in to distribute
water to the people that are affected
but yeah this evacuation effort is
seemingly a still a long way from
completion and in our estimation
certainly it seems as if the river has
risen in certain areas overnight it
looks to be approximately a similar kind
of level to in this area than it was
yesterday we estimate that in some areas
you know it's it's still around sort of
four meters deep could actually be
deeper
so uh yeah as I say the situation here
still die you can see people being
brought in on a boat there
um
as this Mammoth effort to get people who
want to leave their buildings out we've
been looking at the initial stages of
this relief campaign this huge great
evacuation effort and the suffering that
this city has endured and this is our
package
there is a sadness that pervades these
flooded streets
soon after Russia's invasion kerson was
attacked and then occupied by Russian
forces and now large areas of the city
are underwater
many of the people who returned after
the Ukrainian Army retook kerasan late
last year are being evacuated from their
homes again
everything was demolished there it's
frightening the two-story houses have
been swept away and the summer houses
are floating down the river there is no
one there anymore
Ukraine accuses Russia of destroying the
karkov KA Dam on the denipro river and
causing this
a terrorist attack to prevent an advance
across the denipro river towards Russian
occupied Crimea says give
Russia says Ukraine is responsible and
is also moving thousands of people to
safety on the opposite russian-occupied
side of the river
this is one of many streets here in
kerasan City completely flooded we
understand that there were hundreds if
not thousands of people that were living
here until this dam was destroyed and
now
they've all been forced to leave
there are fears about minds that may
have been dislodged and carried into the
City by the flood surge
volunteers prepare boats to help in the
search for more trapped people
cages are packed with panicking cats
we were shouting and banging on Windows
there are no people only animals the
water There is almost over the signposts
evacuation buses are full of the young
and old they take with them a few
belongings and their pets
it's very hard to explain honestly it's
so hard to speak very hard I don't know
where I'm going we were taken out and
now we're on our own
City had already experienced some of the
worst suffering in this war
now amid the flood waters and
destruction its people are forced to
endure even more
Charles Strafford Al Jazeera
Charlie a very powerful report there of
how people on both sides have been
affected now we've heard from Ukrainian
officials they've accused the Russians
of firing at emergency calls have been
rescuing uh and trying to evacuate
people uh there what can you tell us
about this and what's the latest on
fighting elsewhere in Ukraine
yeah we've heard similar reports from
the Ukrainian authorities over the last
couple of days that they accusing
Russian forces of shelling areas near to
where the evacuations are happening
certainly we haven't seen anything like
that in a period of time that we've been
here and there has been no real chatter
about that since but as I say we've
heard a lot of outgoing shelling
certainly on this side over the last
couple of hours and there are concerns
here by the military
that Russian forces May respond with
respect to what's happening in the East
along that thousand or so kilometer
front line East and the South we're
hearing unconfirmed reports of progress
that have been made by Ukrainian forces
in the last couple of days south of
bakmut having been halted by what's
being reported as Russian reinforcements
of course bakmut was declared in full
control by the Russians last months
um we're hearing though that yes as I
say progress is being halted in the
south of the Ukrainian mood and then on
the contrary to that there are reports
that the ukrainians are making gains to
the north of Bahamut more importantly
arguably there's a lot of pro-russian
military blogger chatter about what they
describe as a huge intensification of
fighting and firing artillery being
fired south of zaparizia by Ukrainian
forces at towns like tokmak meliotoppel
as the expected
counter-offensive is believed to now be
beginning and this wouldn't be
inconceivable as certainly military
analysis will tell you that it's very
much in Ukraine's interest to push south
of zapparisha in order to be able to get
to the azov sea in order to cut off this
land bridge between Russian occupied
donetska lugansk and Russian occupied
Crimea but as you can imagine all eyes
are really focused seemingly at the
moment on this huge crisis that's
unfolding in this city and thousands of
square kilometers in this region Charlie
thank you very much for the update
Charles Radford live for us there in
kerson Ukraine